we started LLC when we fight against
those stupid charges that's our duty how
do we make money how do we make money
and then we run into LLC fees and we go
what a scam
[Music]
all right we're gonna go over a bunch of
stuff that
um we kind of just stopped seeing their
everyday things in life that are kind of
scammy but we just accepted it because
you just can't do anything like pay
phones
was like
like things like that yeah
you can't agree with whether or not
these are things that you just now deal
with even though they're unfair the fact
that health insurance doesn't cover
vision or dental yeah the [__] is that
isn't that weird that's so weird I hate
yeah we're paying hundreds of dollars a
month and vision and dental are nice
it's like an add-on I hate it I don't
really understand the way that health
insurance works because like we're
paying so much money and we don't even
use those services and then when you
need the services you still got to pay
like a five thousand dollars well if you
need the services and you already have
that condition they're gonna deny you
because they're like they're gonna cost
us way too much money and it's like yeah
stupid [__] that's like I need your help
yeah should be the whole enchilada like
Vision Dental mental like everything
yeah
here's one that I really don't
understand like you really can't do
anything about it College textbook
prices yeah oh dude what a [__]
schedule a scam because I've been a part
of it what do you mean what the [__] did
you do what were you like uh no no so uh
in college I used to help uh this guy
sell textbooks and the same exact
[__] textbook because of publishing
rights or whatever
in America it'll be like 80 for the
textbook right this guy I don't know how
he sourced them but he'll get the same
exact textbook for five bucks so he's
getting the Pakistan Edition or India
Edition just because it's different
publishingly I was asking like is the
paper weight different or like what is
he goes it's literally exactly the same
thing but it's just how like the I guess
like territories regionals yeah it's
just expensive but the publishing houses
are in America so are we charging
ourselves so much more and so we would
get these textbooks for five bucks
sell it on eBay for 30 or 40. so we're
still getting a killer of a margin it's
insane but the the bookstores here are
getting for five bucks and there's
something like eighty dollars I had a
college professor in community college
and it was like an elective right and it
was uh it was a necessary elective it
was like film history and the teacher
was selling and was Auditorium so it was
a giant class and the teacher had his
own textbook yeah that's the bit that's
a double scam dude and he he's double
tipping he sold the books brand new for
150 dollars it's insane but you needed
to buy it brand new because it all had
your own secret code whatever so you use
your online so you could take the
quizzes online and without the quizzes
in the book you're not gonna pass the
[__] class that is a scam and it's
just like everybody in there had to pay
like 150 bucks so you can't even buy a
used version no you had to buy a brand
it didn't even exist because you need
the code I had to do the same thing with
with uh Cerritos College the teachers
all there all over College are trying to
make their own books for that reason and
then their argument is always like hey
we put in the time and the money for the
research and all this stuff so then like
that but it's just the way it was
history class
yeah yeah if you can't write history we
watch 400 blows or whatever the [__]
that movie was so that's one of the
things they point out is that like the
dumb thing is that they try to make the
books obsolete every year by like making
some mundane changes yeah yeah the
eighth edition the ninth Edition they
changed the sentence yeah but then like
it's English or history or physics where
it hasn't changed in the [__] million
years yeah I think the biggest scam is
college though the way that it's
monetized it's [__] crazy what's the
average like University for your
University cost like I get it when
they used to have a monopoly on
information like it used to be in our
parents generation where you're working
class and the only access you can get
to you know that higher level is going
to a university and then you network
there and you do all that [__] right but
right now with Google and YouTube I
think sometimes you get way better
[__] education and you're getting
access to professionals that are like
way higher at a different level than the
professors that you're talking to yeah
colleges is too expensive it's not like
it's not valuable it's just way too
expensive for what you get I am curious
of which Edition textbooks started
changing the story of Christopher
Columbus
um if they did don't help them okay fine
what's the next one all right next one
is is luxury skin care oh yeah it all
comes from the same Factory and it's
just white labeled what do you mean
there's like three or four factories
that do all of this Korean skin care
products are full and Superior top-notch
those are some stuff do you use the the
sea snail slug no no I don't like snails
skincare [__] but the times that I have
done it you can definitely tell the
difference aren't they cheaper than the
American not the European one the scam
isn't even that it's that the higher up
you go in luxury the more natural the
ingredients get the more simple the
ingredients are well that's like
groceries yeah so you're just putting a
little bit of like and if you were to
buy those things individually the what
the ingredients are yeah you would be
paying probably like one percent of the
costs but I don't want to do all that
because what I know is like for shampoos
and things like that they all come from
the same Factory and it's white labeled
and branded differently yeah so it's the
same ingredient it's like how Kirkland
does it you know like I heard that the
Kirkland Vodka is actually gray
Goosebumps or it's like sunglasses or
like something like but they take the
hit so they can give the value to the
customer Yep this is they pass on to
them I never even thought about this
which I feel like an idiot paying the
same price for a digital and a physical
copy of a video game oh it's the same
price now it's always been I don't know
though yeah like if it's 70 off the
shelf it's 70 on the eShop but we don't
really care we're just like oh okay yeah
if anything if anything you're like um
I'm down to just get this off the
digital because if I get like a new
system I'll just re-download it there
and it's just easy and you're not like
organizing more clutter but it is the
same [__] product but it's the same
exact price and there's an unlimited
quantity it's kind of weird right that
is super weird that's why everything is
like digital everything's digital and
then they then they can sell like
external hard drives and that's a whole
other Market too it's all [__] racket
dude external hard drive yeah the big
push for making games digital is that
that way you can't sell them back or you
can't sell them after you don't like it
or something it's like oh it's just you
have that now sorry yeah diamonds is one
of them too oh yes oh we know that
though yeah that's in but that's the
thing like you just kind of accept it
right yeah you know yeah you can't I
would love for the world to change it
but it's too late now so I'm down for
people to keep on buying them yeah I
don't give a [__] I already got mine
yeah
how about payday loans do you know
anything about payday loans what is that
yeah oh that's they Prey Upon the poor
communities like it's those [__] get
your cash now like those yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and then you can also get
loans there too because you'll be like
oh when I get my paycheck I'll come back
and pay you but they're like 30 APR yeah
and it puts you on like a never-ending
cycle of the next paycheck is paying for
the last loan and then it just goes like
this forever wow because you're you're
kind of like monetizing that lowest
common denominator of earners so you're
like hey all you people who are barely
making it I'm taking your money to give
you money and it tricks the uneducated
uh financially uneducated people to like
yeah that's the Quick Fix yeah yeah it's
so funny it's a heartless like dude when
I was working at the bank um you would
hear like the like personal Bankers or
like the loan people trying to really
like shark at the people that you can
tell are like financially illiterate and
I would listen and I'm like holy [__]
this is horrible like you know this
person's not gonna be able to afford a
credit card or even understand how the
concept of a credit card works and this
person's just pushing it on them and I'm
like no don't do it oh man yeah and then
giving them a high limit of like it's
the worst
dude I'm waiting for you to say Smog
Checks it's not on here I know you don't
like them Small Checks service service
fees on tickets yeah yeah what the [__]
is that all about but you pay it right
you just go all right I have to it's
right there there's like four different
like you're trying to buy Usher tickets
there's this feed this the convenience
fee service fee processing yeah I'm like
I just give me the [__] ticket price
bro dude it's like initiation fees at
gyms like they personally tell you like
oh you could wave it in a way to make
the sale a little bit easier you know oh
it's wave now like oh thank you so much
like thank you for doing that for me
wow so cool yeah yeah pump your signing
endorphins we don't have that at Barbara
Brigade because we're stupid but we only
have one price
hey here's uh
here's one that maybe some of you guys
can answer funeral services
well that's a little too like Fast all
right like it just happened let the body
get cold before we start making jokes
what happened to you somebody else's dad
die
barbecue funeral services
it's kind of [__] I feel like this
should be one of those things I mean
yeah I feel like it should be warnings
were like because do they it says they
try to upsell you did that happen oh
[__] yeah there you go for sure but they
don't judge you which is kind of cool
like they'll be like um they're like oh
which like themed which earn or whatever
you want to put the the ashes in or they
call it the love would you want to put
your loved ones in yeah I don't know
which one's the cheapest one it's like
this box and then they're like oh this
one right here and this most
eco-friendly box you know like but have
you seen this you know they're always
like have you seen have you this just be
like can I just put them in this
Kirkland bottle
but it was Ziploc bags hella [__]
expensive like I went the cheapest on
everything on my pops because also I
know that's just what he would want he's
a very practical person he would have
want the Kirkland deal on that I think
uh having had his plot already paid for
I still have to pay like almost 10 G's
on the cheapest [__] it's already paid
for it his plot is already paid for but
just on the urn and then whatever like
all the other processes like the
refrigeration fee or the [__]
transfer fee I don't know there's a
billion fees oh yeah there's like oh if
ever and you have to get every death
certificate is a is a different price
you gotta yeah you got to get all this
[__] yo if I pass just throw me a
dumpster dude there's a lot I don't want
a bird in my family with any of that
[__] yeah dude gosh dude dude I remember
kind of like yelling a little bit at the
lady doing all the arrangements because
my dad had just passed and I'm the one
handling all of this stuff and then
they're trying to upsell you and I was
just like
what did I tell I forgot what I said but
I was just like I don't want anything
else just pick just whatever I pick
that's it don't talk to me about
anything else mention other [__] yeah
and I feel bad for them because she's
just doing her job and I was like I want
nothing else just what I picked but
that's it that's definitely not the
first time she's ever had a deal with
someone that felt that way you know what
I mean like she knows what she knows
she's a hard sale but I got her
condition yourself to like upsell that
you know you're dealing with [__]
loved ones that pass and you you might
be dealing with households that just
lost their Prime earner yeah and you're
still trying to gout and you chose that
profession yeah yeah and you're good at
it
sell anything else I'm sure you'd be
good at it yeah yeah but again like like
they're saying we don't do anything
about it we just go hey that's this is
what it is you know why because I think
it's not a reoccurring charge thing so
most things that get changed are like
you have to deal with it every day and
you're like [__] [__] but like if you
deal with these situations just once and
then you're done and you don't have to
run into it ever again like you're never
gonna fight it their business model is
to milk you for that one sale guys I say
we do this starting today we start
funeral services no no we started an LLC
where we fight against those stupid
charges that's our duty how do we make
money how do we make money how do we
make money from this and then we run
into LLC fees and we go what a scam
damn it
[Music]